I'm going to be presenting a hypothesis
on the hypothesis that explains how
optimization occurs in simple genetic
algorithms with uniform crossover a
uniform crossover was first used by
actly in 1970s this 1987 and it's and it
was since popularized by SIA and others
and there are numerous accounts of
optimization by genetic algorithms that
use uniform crossover and in practice
there is a finding that it frequently
performs crossover with tight linkage
amongst the genetic loci uniform
crossover I guess it's it's it's more a
computer and evolutionary computation
term it basically just means pre
recombination and we'll we'll go over
what what that what that is in a in a
second just we just aren't nail things
down now the thing about uniform
crossover is that it's effectivity
cannot be explained within the rubric of
the building block hypothesis which kind
of tries to explain what goes on in
evolutionary algorithms with tight
linkage between genetic loci and no
viable alternative hypothesis has been
proposed to explain optimization and
genetic algorithms with uniform
crossover so what I'm gonna present is
something called the hype of climbing
hypothesis and it's a it's an
explanation for how optimization occurs
in these simple genetic algorithms that
use uniform crossover so I'm just gonna
hone in on this this scientific
explanation and talk about that for a
second what do we mean by scientific I
so there's one there's one kind of
approach where you say that which is the
logical positivist approach which is
proof or bust you know prove it
or you know go home and there the
emphasizes the emphasis is on
verifiability no proof you know no cigar
and then there's the preparing method
which says that scientific truth is
provisional and the emphasis is on
falsifiability you know you're allowed
to make the hypothesis and as long as
you know you can make testable
predictions if those predictions come
true then then you know melenz krita's
credence to be to the hypothesis and
there's additional typing with
additional tightening where we're in if
the proof if the if what's predicted is
unexpected then the theory deserves more
credence so for example Einstein's
theory of gravitational lensing was
Ben's theory of general relativity
predicted gravitational lensing which
was completely unexpected and then you
know it was found to to be true in
practice and that greatly enhanced the
reputation of Einstein's theory of
gravitational lensing so we can ask for
additional requirements here we can say
well I want to assume very little about
the distribution of fitness you know a
typical if you have a theory about how
evolutionary algorithms work you're
going to make some assumptions about the
the fitness function that evolutionary
algorithms encounter in practice and we
want to make sure that those are really
really weak which is just Occam's razor
applied to evolutionary computation we
want an upfront proof of concept and so
that's to avoid another Royal Roads
moment and that's that's kind of in
genetic algorithm lore where the Royal
Roads was a fitness function that was
tailor-made to play to the advantages of
genetic algorithms with tight linkage
and on that fitness functions genetic
algorithms with one point crossover
tight linkage failed pretty badly and
was kind of an embarrassing moment so we
don't want a repeat of that we want to
come up with a Royal Roads function that
you know works in this case and what
would be really nice to have is that if
we is that we can identify some kind of
core computational efficiency at play
and I'm talking from a theoretical
computer science standpoint you know Big
O of something where where you're
working with a hard problem and you're
giving bounds that are quite surprising
so I'm going to do all of these things
the hyperfine hypothesis is that genetic
algorithms with uniform crossover
perform adaptation by implementing a
global search heuristic called hyper
climbing so that's the abstract
heuristic you can pick up the genetic
algorithm as the machine code and we're
after what is that abstract heuristic
that that it's implementing so we're
going to talk about the uniform
crossover operator we're going to
describe hyper climbing we're going to
show a proof of concept the Royal Roads
basically that genetic algorithm can
implement hyper climbing efficiency and
you know if we have time then we'll you
know talk about predictions and
validations on max 3sat and the spins
class spin glasses problem so uniform
crossover it probably doesn't need very
much explanation here but I'm going to
I'm going to talk about it because I
want to highlight certain symmetries of
uniform crossover that get used in the
in kind of the reasoning here
so essentially you take two bit string
genomes you line them up there are you
have a string of random binary variables
if I write as a binary variable resolves
to one value then you pick from B from
the top row if it resolves to another
value you pick from the bottom row so
you get a child genome and you subject
that
- mutation mutation again can be can be
modeled with random binary variables if
it's if it's you know one value then you
don't mutate if it's another value then
you mutate the debate now the key point
here is that uniform crossover in
uniform crossover these x's that that
you use to do the crossover operation
they're independent that's not true for
you know one point crossover or you know
other kinds of crossover these are
independent in uniform crossover and
what that translates into is an absence
of positional bias you can arbitrarily
permute the bits in a genome and then
permute them back after crossover and
you won't have any there's no issue with
doing that if you use uniform crossover
and if in addition you're the the random
variables describing mutation are also
independent and independent of the
number of bits in your bit strings then
then there's the case that if if some
look locus in your population is
immaterial - Fitness doesn't play a part
in Fitness in other words if your
fitness function is sparse it only
depends on the values at a few low side
then you can splice those low side out
and and you know what the dynamics you
see after splicing them out will be the
fitness dynamics you see after splicing
those low side would be what you would
see with those low side present
I wanted to be such that kind of your
interpretation with probability 1 over L
no because then you can't slice them out
right take away what you do but just
look how people use mutation and
evolutionary algorithms some yeah some
people some people mutate based on the
number of bits in the genome and I'm
saying that's not the case here you have
each the mutation has to be independent
of the number of bits right but in this
case we're not doing that I mean people
people people do that for whatever
reason I'm saying in this set up you
know to bring out the computational
efficiency we're not going to do that
and that then allows us to splice out
splice out these slice at the low side
that are immaterial and basically what
I'm talking about the splicing out
business is basically your post
screening the dynamics and so if you've
got a setup like this you can you can
just kind of purely purely using a
symmetry argument cause during the
dynamics of a of a genetic algorithm
with uniform crossover so what is the
hyper climbing eristic it's actually
it's it's cool in that it's stable in
terms of FEMA and schema partitions all
the old machinery that Holland developed
is applicable here but the sort of final
story is is somewhat different and so
the setting is that you've got search
space which Maps where and a function a
fitness function that map's bit strings
to real values and in this case the
function may be stochastic so you know
you're not always going to get the same
ultimate values given a particular bit
string
we can talk about and so given given how
does this work
there we go given bit strings of length
L we can define an index set which
contains elements of in 1 to L and this
index set basically partitions the
search space into 2 to the K schemata
where K is the cardinality of the the
index set and we'll and let's just
denote this partition by you know these
double brackets around the around the
index set and so here's an example for
for you know I equals 3 comma 7 you're
basically partitioning the the search
space into these Scimitar now this the
coarseness of this partition is
determined by K as you can see and
you're going to have L choose K schema
partitions of order K so that's because
there are there are L choose K possible
index sets now for for fixed a fixed
value of K this is bounded L choose K is
bounded from below by L to the power of
of K and when L is a very large number
say a million you know you're gonna have
you know even for for very coarse
partitions you know cave and before
you're gonna have a very large number of
course schema partitions it's just one
other definition and then we can get to
the good stuff so the effect of a schema
partition is nothing but the variance of
the average fitness of the schemata in
in the in the partition and as you can
see as you start making as use as you
start sort of removing elements from
this index set you're going to have a
smaller and smaller effect because
you're basically averaging
over stuff that used to be in separate
pockets so you know that's a basic
definition of effect here so what is a
how does a hyper climbing heuristic work
what it does is out of this potentially
vast space of course partitions it finds
of course partition with with a
detectable effect now you know
intuitively you might when you when
you're talking about this vast space of
course partitions and you know which are
basically divisions of the of the search
space
most of the those coarse partitions are
not going to have much of an effect
they're not the Fitness is not going to
separate out nicely but in a few cases
there may be cost partitions where it
does the hypo climbing heuristic will
detect that and it will limit futures
sampling of the search space to a schema
in this partition with above-average
fitness and in doing so it basically
raises the fitness of future samples
because you're limiting it to a schema
with higher than average expected
fitness and what so what does limiting
future sampling to some schema mean it
basically means that you're you are
fixing the the defining bits of the
scheme that schema in the population and
now you can recur sand and hypercam and
you can do the same thing over the unfix
loose I in the population so that
basically in a nutshell is the hyper
climbing heuristic now there's a key
assumption here that when you fix
certain what what is important portent
is that there may be what I call
conditional attacks when you fix a bunch
of low sigh
you may now create a condition where you
know certain low sigh certain partitions
have an effect where before they didn't
have an effect so that's that's this
case that's what's that's something that
I called
cause conditional effects and there they
are that's a weak weaker assumption on
the distribution of fitness over over
search space then what the building
block hypothesis assumes which is
unstirred of course unconditional
effects and these weaker assumptions are
therefore more likely to be satisfied in
practice and that's good because we want
to explain optimization in genetic
algorithms with uniform crossover on the
widest possible range of fitness
functions now the thing to point out is
that what I've described here the hyper
climbing heuristic it's an example of
what what I call what's called a
decimation heuristic and as such it's a
pretty good company because decimation
heuristics iteratively they're class of
heuristics that iteratively reduce the
size of a search space by by finding and
fixing partial solutions and there's no
backtracking allowed and survey
propagation which is the state of the
art solver for random satisfiability
problems really large random
satisfiability problems operates in this
fashion by basically fixing low sigh one
by one so what I'm going to give you is
a proof of concept here and it's going
to be interesting given the talks that
we've had you know earlier in the week
because I'm gonna talk about how an
evolutionary algorithm with uniform
crossover can can solve sparse parities
which is which kind of goes against what
we heard earlier in the week but there's
there's a way that it doesn't that that
the efficient computation occurring here
doesn't quite fit into valiance model
which is why it actually does occur
according to valiance model if it if it
did fit in then there'd be a problem
with this work clearly because you know
within that model you you know parity
cannot be done efficiently well out here
we'll find out that partly can be done
very efficiently in fact so the set up
is this
you've got the fitness of any particular
bit string so there are better basically
you know this is the parity from the
parity learning parties problem you've
got you've got four low side you know so
k is for out here and if if for any bit
string if the parity of the bits at
those four low psy is odd then you draw
your you draw the fitness of that bit
string from this distribution otherwise
you draw it from this distribution and
these are just Gaussian distributions
with you know mean plus 0.25 and minus
point two five and standard deviation 1
and so again the game is you know these
are your the the low side that matter
and but but the algorithm doesn't know
that and and your and the algorithms job
is to say is - like identify which low
psy matter given you know it can query
and it can get values back and its job
at the end of the day is to say those
red ones are the low side that matter
here now the this party learning problem
is interesting because the naive
approach of of visiting Llosa in groups
of four to figure it out the time
complexity of that is you know it's
bounded from below by L to the power of
four and you know a pre approaching low
psy in groups of one won't work
approaching low silent groups of two
won't work in you know in terms of in
groups of three won't work
if you're trying to like search for
marginal for expected marginal fitness
you have to visit in groups of four and
so what I'm going to show you now is
what happens when I run a population
it's a very simple genetic algorithm
uniform crossover
it's got Sigma scaling and and
stochastic Universal sampling which are
which are pretty standard operations
what you're going to see here I'm
plotting the population here and what
what you're seeing is the marginal the
marginals at each each low size so it's
a number of ones in the population at
each locus is what
so these dots are going to move up and
down as the frequency of the number of
one's changes as evolution proceeds the
red dots are the relevant bits of the
parity function and we want we want the
genetic algorithm to identify them oops
here we go
so boom the important so now you can
just go and read off the the location of
the parity of the parity lo sigh and you
know it happened in 500 generations now
now where where is the efficiency this
is just one run
you know so what I'm gonna do here is
I'm gonna tack on another I'm gonna tack
on another 8 800 lo sigh so I am vastly
increasing the number of course schema
partitions of order 4 and let's see how
long it takes to find those the parity
bits again within under you know 500
generations yes yes well I didn't watch
it i but i but I read about it
I read his I read newspaper before that
there is a polynomial this is actually
this is poly log a logarithmic actually
I haven't I have a proof that you can do
this in in poly logarithmic time in in n
the number of the the number of low sy
it's not published but and so here's
here's you know you're adding so dynamic
now I'm looking at 10,000 loose I so
vastly again increasing the the the
number of course partitions and again it
will identify the the parity bits in in
under 500 generations and so you know
what's what's what's the deal because
you know valiance folks said that you
know you can't do parity with evolution
and here I'm saying you can and the
difference is that valiance I'm doing
something which I don't know is whether
it's quite allowed in balance model
which which is I'm looking over the
entire population and Valiant
you know you're you're limited to like
looking at each the fitness of each
individual point again and and also my
points out here are just bit strings
whereas valiance points are hypotheses
about that valiance point you know
values
you can't do much so silently once model
doesn't fit into the valiant model I
think yeah I definitely what to do
right right yeah I I know I was I'm
definitely going to look enough so yeah
so so now to take this idea and show you
hyper climbing in sort of full full
generality or what I've been trying to
do just is just to show you sort of the
basic what you know the smallest the the
computational efficiency in it in its
most basic form and here you know I want
to show it to you in full generality and
so the setup here is that you know if
you've got two matrices if the third
eight eighty eighty seven and ninety
third loose I r101
then draw the you know then draw the
Fitness from this distribution otherwise
draw the distribution of otherwise draw
a fitness on this distribution if in
addition you know the poly second 58.7
he tells seventy-second low saya one
zero zero zero then draw a fitness from
here you know otherwise your you know
stuff here and so on and so forth down
here
and I call these staircase functions and
you know when when you take this high
dimensional space that there's a way you
can use something called dimensional
stacking and view it on a
two-dimensional plot and it looks
something like this and of course you
can play with you can play with the the
signal strength you can change the
Sigma's again and and so you can you can
you can
you can you can sort of play around with
with this and so here is a genetic
algorithm with uniform crossover and one
of these functions and so you can see it
finds the first set of dots it finds the
second and so on and of course I mean I
blind these up outlined these dots up
but they need not be lined up they could
be in this fashion and still the genetic
algorithm would sort of identify the
right partitions and and you know hone
in on a particular piece of the search
space and here it is with 5,000 lows I
and so basically the other the
irrelevant close I just don't you know
you know pretty much don't matter to the
genetic algorithm it it is able to
efficiently evolve despite the existence
of a lot of irrelevant like
dimensionality you could say okay and
the rest of it is prediction about
validation which I'll spare you but I
you know I make a prediction I validate
that it's true on max at and the spin
classes fitness functions and you can
look that up on my blog it's called evil
Rhythmics
just Google Everett mix and stop there
thank you
so I bet the petition called beautiful
prostate which is basically very weak
correlation no no no correlation
basically okay have you tried writing
down the difference equations for the
rate of change I have the other point is
that you mentioned I was Freud on the
scale after itself but it sounds a bit
like fishes I've mentioned which says
that the change in Wii Fitness or
generation interception is equal to the
total juice
in this interaction order right and so I
mean I would say that this almost says
that you can you can you can have cases
where there there's you know with the
parity basically there is no additive
you know there are no fullest ordered
effects there are there are no second
order effect or not third order only
both order class and so yes
yes yes yeah so but but thickening at
the bigger yep in a dynamic way yes you
have you do then have these effects even
I've even first order effects but at the
beginning you know if you if you're
something from a uniform population
there are no you know first second
colored order of things
yes yes yeah that's why this this
wouldn't work with infinite and an
infinite population polynomial in for
alright and and what is it in n
interesting okay I definitely need of
saying investigate by is useful in
genetic algorithms but then what you're
doing is not really an optimization
problem
I mean your original optimization
problem basically just as to fitness
levels kind of zero and one depending on
whether these four bits are but what
you're doing is something what you're
aiming at is something more than
optimizing this problem because they're
trying to find where these four bits are
right so what I'm saying is that in the
solving of the optimization problem
there is a learning problem that gets
solved repeatedly and that learning
problem doesn't doesn't have to do with
optimization it has to do with
identifying identifying bits identifying
low-side that are relevant and fixing
them to some particular values and so
you have the repeated you know you have
the repeated solving of a learning
problem which you know the who's who's
ultimate effect is I wouldn't say
optimization but just adaptation because
we know you know we know that these
things aren't necessarily geared to find
the global optimum
optimal in any way and after how this
adaptation occurred and what I'm saying
is it's through this repeated solving of
a of this learning problem my title said
adaptation explaining adaptation and
genetic algorithms with uniform
crossover yeah I mean it I think it's
it's you know even stuff like first
hitting time and things like that I
think it's I don't I think it might be
barking up the wrong tree of it because
we don't expect evolutionary algorithms
to find Optima often we apply them to
np-hard and be complete problems where
you know we know it's going to be
exponential so so you know focusing on
how long it takes to find a global
optimum seems to it seems to me to be
you know
kind of a little bit miss please